what's wubble and dub dubs it's me Mt
and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show this is a breakdown of the body
snatching therapy session that is the
third episode of Rick and Morty season 7
so sit back grab a snack and maybe call
your ex-girlfriend Hive mine back
because we about to get into it and the
episode starts with the return of Susan
sandon in the role of Dr Wong a
character who first appeared in the
iconic pickle Rick episode back in
season 3 episode 3 though it is kind of
crazy to see how things have progressed
between Dr wrong and a rick who
literally turned himself into a pickle
to avoid going to therapy because now
Rick seems a lot more receptive to
therapy and has been going to therapy
regularly enough for Dr Wong to know
whether or not Rick is using a hologram
or some other scientific tactic to avoid
having to go too deep into his feelings
or motivations we get a reference to the
popular onion ring snack brand funions
after Rick's hologram gets called out
and he whips out the bag of funions that
he was looking for behind Dr Wong's
couch and then when Rick leaves the
therapy office office to talk to Keith
David's president Curtis he's surrounded
by soldiers in high-tech military grade
monoculars that very much remind me of
the scouters that Vegeta and the saans
used in Dragon Ball Z the president then
yells at Rick and tells him that when he
calls Rick directly that it's an
emergency a line that Rick would yell
back to the president later on in the
episode after Curtis Dodges Rick's call
that would have warned him about the
presence of unity in the state of
Virginia and right after we learned that
the mess the president needs Rick to
clean up has to do with the Mythic Loch
Ness monster having gone experimentation
very similar to that of the X-Man
Wolverine with the American Military
having given old Nessy titanium bones at
a secret government facility at Lake
Erie much like Logan was experimented on
at a secret base at Alkali Lake and when
Rick apologizes to the president's
Secret Service Guard for calling
scientologists space Mormons he mentions
that he likes the actor Tom Cruz who is
of course the Scientology religion's
most popular member president Curtis
would take his own jab at those
problematic people when he would compare
scientologists to the body snatching
hive mind that his Scientologist
bodyguard calls the possessed Virginians
however I really enjoyed seeing Rick
apologize to that bodyguard though
because it really does show that he is
taking therapy to heart and that some
part of Rick recognizes that the road of
Rick Prime Revenge that he's been going
down this season has been causing him to
become a jerk to his family and
everybody around him and that is some
serious growth for someone who once
installed a freaking incinerator over Dr
Wong's chair just in case she were to
ask something too invasive and that type
of growth would of course lead Rick to
silently apologize to Summer after he
blows up at her in the garage later on
in the episode and after the theme intro
plays we get this season's very first
look at some interdimensional cable as
Rick and Morty watched the Mr stabby
talk show with voice acting Legend Tom
Kenny of SpongeBob and Adventure Time
Fame voicing the homicidal host Mr
stabby would of course show up again dur
during the post-credit scene of this
episode as he talks to an alien parody
of Larry King about his steptacular
approach to working and murking his
audience and as the two watch the
program Rick drinks his favorite beer
brand foy's Genuine Draft beer which is
the Rick and mor universe's take on the
Miller brand beers Genuine Draft
collection and then when Rick heads on
over to the White House after being
summoned the president has a district
map of Virginia on the screen and since
the president's problem was in the state
of Virginia Rick iously assumes that the
problem has to do with something Bigfoot
related or racism with one of the
president's military personnel
immediately outing themselves as another
secret racist in the American government
which is painfully accurate to reality
and speaking of Bigfoot the alien that
may or may not be able to draw the
future draws Rick being killed by a
Bigfoot like monster in the future
possibly implying a major wounding
coming Rick's way sometime later on this
season because I have a feeling that
this alien can actually see the future
but anyways when the president recruits
Dr Wong on his weird Guardians of the
Galaxy ass team of random aliens he
offers her a complimentary gun which I
thought was a funny piece of commentary
on how loose the American government is
with how easily anyone in the country
can acquire a dangerous weapon they
practically give that away and
after Dr Wong convinces Virginia to open
up its borders for them we can see that
the president made a picture of Rick and
him taking down the scientific
abomination of a Loch Ness monster as
his phone background and that they both
seemingly somehow managed to take Nessie
down with regular ass fishing equipment
which is hilarious and suspicious
because those two black eyes in the Loch
Ness monster seem to tell another more
brutal Tale But I'm just saying but
anyways when Rick arrives on the scene
he immediately identifies the phenomenon
in Virginia to be the doing of his
former partner Unity as voiced by
actress Christina hris of Mad Men Fame
once again since her first appearance as
unity in season 2 episode 3's autoerotic
assimilation an episode that ended with
unity Le leaving Rick after realizing
that being with Rick was changing them
for the worst and causing them to
embrace extremely self-destructive
behaviors at the cost of the stability
of their hive mind that they built like
I really enjoy Unity as a character
because although unity's actions of
taking over people's bodies and planets
is extremely unethical Unity herself is
actually a really kind and thoughtful
being towards the people that they care
about so much so that they went out of
their way to make sure that their ex
wasn't about to hurt himself by
reigniting his unhealthy obsession with
finding and eliminating Rick Prime
because that dude almost died last time
like the whole reason why the events of
this episode even happened is because
Rick was unable to accept why Unity left
him in the first place with Rick even
admitting that his anger at Unity
ghosting him caused him to ghost her
phone calls to check in on him and make
sure that he was okay Unity has not
really done anything to Rick
specifically to make him not trust them
so Unity hearing Rick openly confess to
not trusting them despite all of that
deeply hurt Unity to the point of unity
reciprocating that distrust back to Rick
by the end of the episode but anyways I
love how Rick tricks Unity into
revealing that they were still in
possession of Dr Wong's Body by
purposely calling Dr Wong a nutritionist
instead of a therapist which leads Unity
to immediately take the bait and pretend
to be a nutritionist and begin a long
rant about nutritionism before
immediately getting sprayed by Rick and
shortly after we learned that President
Curtis and Rick have seemingly worked
together to place energy domes around
every state in the United States
including Virginia with the Dome Central
Energy unit having been hidden inside of
the Virginia Washington Monument in
Richmond and later while the president
regroups in his situation room there is
a table in the shape of a pentagon
possibly implying that they're meeting
inside of the Pentagon itself and then
when Rick and Curtis threaten each other
over the president's advances on Dr Wong
Rick's cyborg body shoots out some Dr
Octopus style arms equipped with a taser
a boxing glove a high Tech Boomerang a
plasma cannon some type of poisonous
needle thing an energy sword with a
laser coming out of the bottom kylo Ren
style and most hilariously a
presidential recall referendum just in
case all those other weapons fail Rick
brought the most powerful weapon of all
democracy and later when the president
is on his way to gas the population of
Virginia the positioning of the cannon
was of course Very Much intended to
symbolize the president having a big
penis implying that his deep desire to
gas everyone for the approval of the
Nation shows that he's trying to make up
for feelings of inferiority in his
masculinity and then later on when Rick
and Dr Wong are heading to make peace
with unity after the president infects
the state of Virginia with his
Consciousness Rick tells Dr Wong to
convince Unity that he's worth it to
which Rick's own therapist says that
he's not which is an extremely
inappropriate thing for a therapist to
say to their own patient but hey after
all this time dealing with the Smith
family I'm pretty sure Dr Wong has grown
quite tired with all of their and
is about one Smith family therapy
session away from retiring from her
profession completely but after Rick and
Dr Wong managed to convince Unity to
initiate a friendly planetary Invasion
to save the world from an unhinged
President we see their Invasion Fleet
stopped by New York City the Gateway
Arch in St Louis Missouri the Hollywood
Hills the Golden Gate Bridge in San
Francisco as well as Las Vegas Nevada
and in Las Vegas luxer hotel
advertisements for the Blue Man Group as
well as famous Vegas comedic magician
the amazing Jonathan can be seen while
the vomit Invasion starts Popp and off
however the most important Easter egg of
this episode comes in the form of this
President possessed man right here who
is repping the most important number of
all time 69 the number of Champions the
number of gods and the number you should
dial for a damn good time and finally
after Unity is forced to release
billions of people from her control all
at once I love how the show depicts the
human race as already being part of
their own hive mind groups already
whether it's everyone always being on
their phone all the time or how everyone
has been programmed to live their lives
in traffic while going to their
regularly scheduled 9 to5 jobs or just
waste their time on the internet reading
the same useless garbage like I
genuinely love every time Unity comes
around Rick and Morty because her
presence kind of makes you question
whether or not Humanity being taken over
by a genuinely kind hive mind would be
an upgrade for the planet you know just
like Unity did in their debut episode
when they took over an alien planet
parody of Earth filled with the most
violent and hateful people ever but all
in all this episode of Rick and mor was
a super interesting look into how Rick's
angry nature continues to push the
people that care about him away and how
Rick is beginning to recognize that in
himself while honestly trying to be a
better person like this season seems to
be heavily centered around Rick
confronting his own inner demons while
also trying not to lose himself during
his hunt for the evil Rick Prime and I'm
super excited to see how Rick's
character continues to progress
throughout this season because it seems
like they're setting up some really
interesting stuff but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video and
if you want another great Rick Morty
breakdown do not forget to check out the
YouTube channel Whitney Vision where my
girl Whitney van laningham is always
breaking down everything animation and
she is the best at it so go check out
Whitney Vision today but anyways you can
follow me at mastertainment on Instagram
Twitter or wherever if you guys want to
see me post some weird but most
importantly don't forget to follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube and on Twitter
so you can keep up to date with
everything that we post at all times but
yeah thanks again for watching I love
you guys so much I'll see you guys next
time bye